let's get into audience questions for
the week first one comes from Doug who
says hey David you've mentioned
cryptocurrency off and on you've also
mentioned being on the steam it platform
which is a crypto based content platform
can you tell us in the audience what
crypto currencies you currently hold I'm
opening up a can of worms now because I
will anytime I mention a cryptocurrency
that I hold in passing am I not going to
have to issue a disclosure I honestly I
don't think I do because I own such
small amounts of these things that there
is no possible way that I could in any
way truly benefit from a few extra
people making a transaction or whatever
but I will time willing to disclose Pat
if you will allow it I am basically in
six crypto currencies right now okay for
about a year I've been just buying
little amounts of Bitcoin etherium and
litecoin
which are three of the bigger crypto
currencies Bitcoin of course being like
the first major one that now has been
around for many many years I've been
doing what's called dollar cost
averaging in which means you buy a
little bit at a time
weekly or monthly or whatever and
accumulate it over time so that's what
I'm doing with those three I've more
recently gotten involved in neo which is
a new I don't remember if it's Hong Kong
or China based cryptocurrency and it's
built on another cryptocurrency which
sounds weird but it's called gas GA s so
I'm in neo and gas mostly because why
did I pick that one this is not
investment advice by the way to be 100%
clear I have some people that I trust
who sent me some interesting white
papers on neo and gas and I read about
it and I thought I want to get into
these couple and then as you know
because the David Pakman show is on
Steam it which is ste MIT by sort of
definition
I am also holding steam which is another
cryptocurrency that works specifically
within that universe within the steam it
universe and on some other websites that
are built on it so that's where I am and
I'm not you know there are people who
spend their days day trading crypto
currencies Bitcoin goes up to 98 hundred
dollars and they sell and then it
drops to 9600 and they buy it again and
then it goes 9700 and they sell it I'm
not doing that as people know my my
general investment but philosophy is buy
and hold and I think that by holding
these six hopefully over the long term
there will be appreciation I'm just
gonna say I mean the price of Bitcoin
has exploded I mean especially so even
over the past few weeks it's just his
10,000 that's crazy even over the last
few days I mean it's crazy what's been
going on with this thought I checked it
over Thanksgiving it was maybe around
8,000 that's exactly right now it's over
ten
III mean I hate to say this because it's
such you know these FOMO missed
opportunity things they only serve as
ways to feel bad about your decisions
but about seven years ago I gave a
presentation in Amherst Massachusetts
about the David Pakman show and I was
one of 20 presenters that night and one
of the other presenters that night was
one of the earliest Bitcoin sort of
founder advocates a guy named Gavin
Andresen and at the time I think Bitcoin
costs like a few cents or maybe 50 cents
or something like that and a couple of
the people in the room said I like Gavin
and this sounds interesting enough I'm
gonna put in 500 bucks just to be nice
to be nice I'm gonna put in 500 bucks
and when you think about the change in
value of something and I don't know
exactly where it was seven years ago but
it was very low I mean to say it was at
$1 at the most I don't know it was that
between pennies and a couple bucks to
$10,000 a Bitcoin it is it is absolutely
insane but I try to not feel bad about
it you know ya notice have you've never
heard of those people ever again yes
they're off in the Seychelles hanging
out that's exactly right yes for the tax
benefits no doubt so anyway those are
the kryptos that I'm currently holding
and nothing I've said should be should
be interpreted as any kind of investment
advice whatsoever mostly because I don't
know what the hell I'm doing